You don't need Botox. All you need is a banana peel.
Inside, a banana peel contains lutein,
which is amazing for brightening the skin,
fine lines and wrinkles, and also for fading hyperpigmentation.
You're gonna go ahead and rub this banana peel on your skin.
It's brightening, hydrating,
and soothing. Just think of it as preventative Botox
and focus it on your fine lines and wrinkles
and anywhere you have hyperpigmentation.
Do this as much as possible throughout the week,
and you are going to see a huge difference in just the brightening,
the hydration, and the texture of your skin.
I remember my mom doing this almost every single day.
Anytime there was a banana,
she would make us eat the banana and she take the peel.
So once you're done rubbing it,
just leave it on for 10 minutes
and then go ahead and wash it off with warm water.
Do this consistently, and I can promise you you're not gonna need Botox.
How easy was that?